hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the worst world cup of
your life now this is actually a fan
made game from the ground up no unity
completely made in flash I think about a
video that I did a while ago called
super squat simulator that was just
totally ridiculous and I made it out of
my butt and it was just stupid jokes in
it but hey it's it's it's now a game
it's a game I can't believe it's a game
oh you want to make your home country
proud yes yes indeed I do press button
no I know make my home country proud I
fail home country oh I'm sorry I need to
read press space for all press spacebar
as fast as you can until you're out of
bed oh okay come on excellent alright
let me actually read these instructions
click the squat button to do squats do
as many as you can within the time limit
okie dokie okay oh oh I gotta actually
click that thing okay got it got it got
it look at me go I'm so fit Ludwig von
balling crusher is strong almost too
strong to be asked before me
I even supervene Northend thing this is
my best
Russian accent that I can do I can't
really do it use the arrow keys to move
the spacebar to jump collect gold medals
while avoiding silver and bronze I say
one day we go through Olympics that day
is Tom yes don't want to get silver and
bronze those are for me we'd be baby
countries nor for Scotland I think I
mean is like Scotland Russia is what I
call the country that I was from
originally
you know Ludwig von balling Kruschev Oh
oh my god I'm so sorry I accidently got
two bronze medals I think
to fail my home country not this time ha
ha began must get only gold or nothing
nothing's good 2 way to pro in dd-do IM
okay sorry for spitting so much actually
I am
click the potatoes to bounce them under
the grocery store scanner buy as many as
you can within the time limit
bye bye what did i do sell all my gold
medals to buy potatoes oh that is that
thing I said isn't it ok I get it I get
it I get it I get can i clicking no I
can't click and drag it just got a
clicking ok I got it I'm all about this
I understand what you saying get where
you're thrown out I'm picking up what
you're putting down and I'm putting
potatoes in the basket if you know what
I mean can't believe I can't believe
that this was made into a game that was
a while ago so this must have been like
being developed for a while see how you
gonna make your home country proud if
you're not Scott and Russian Latvian
trying to scrape Taylor squats for
potatoes use the arrow keys and the
spacebar to jump run until Scotland
Russia and Scotland are one so I did say
that I did say that it was that way no
exploded why was I not supposed to go
towards a big phallic looking pillar
over there oh ok be right back okay guys
I'm officially back so I'm not supposed
to go that way I wasn't supposed to
return just yet mr. Venus pillar so I
gotta go over to Scott Oh Oh God
okay this time I'm not messing around I
gotta get Scotland there now no no no go
go go go no time to waste nope nope nope
go go go go
Yoho radical okay work for a home
country be great for Mother Russia it's
good the big lair use left mouse button
to click and drag spacebar Center in
space and conquer the Milky Way first
God Russia I gotta be quick about this
only have 10 seconds okay run run run
run run run run run good God I better
get this I better not dick with me you
ass - Go Go Go Go give me give me quick
quick like money quick like money quick
like money wait like bunny oh this is a
quick enough quick like bunny oh my god
get it Oh God oh my goodness that was
too close
couldn't give me one more second oh man
Scott right yeah of course
here we go oh hey I met them that's
awesome that's so cool I didn't know
that I met them anyway thank you so much
San art for making that game for me you
guys try to beat my high score I think
it was like 367 it's in the video you
can see how much I made but anyway whew
that was frustrating and
little tense there but that was pretty
good I like that laughs thank you so
much for taking the time to make them
thank you guys so much for watching this
it's so cool
so it made me game so thank you guys and
as always I will see you in the next
Bob